we all know last week was incredibly  tense until the election  was finally called on saturday  but now it is over and uh i don't care  what anyone says joe biden  is going to be the 46th president of the  united states  and so i thought it might be nice  if everybody myself the crew here  andy if we all took one  big collective sigh of relief just  bring a lot of air into our lungs and  then just let it  out and just just let our shoulders drop  you ready for this andy wouldn't it be  nice i've been ready for four years  yes okay i know you've been turning blue  the last two years  i have uh okay here we go all right  everyone bring that air into your lungs  and then on three let it out one two  three  oh  whoa that felt really good except for  that last part where there was a lot of  destruction  i didn't see that coming  you